♪ (SOFT MUSIC PLAYS)
SPEAKER: If you mention
the submarine trial,
as we call it here,
everyone will know
what it's about.
SPEAKER 2: Kim was naturally
inclined for journalism.
SPEAKER 3: The stories she
sought out were not mainstream.
SPEAKER 4: The first thought
I had in my head was...
"What do you mean
she's missing?"
SPEAKER 5:
She was just doing her job.
Then she ran into a psychopath.
SPEAKER 6: Peter Madsen
is a very well-known figure.
SPEAKER 7: He's thought of
like an Elon Musk.
He's a major innovator.
SPEAKER 8: Kim Wall went on
the submarine with Peter Madsen
to interview him.
The submarine goes down.
One person comes back.
Where's the other person?
SPEAKER 3:
She was taken from the world
by an act of violence.
He killed her because he could.
This court case was a circus.
SPEAKER 9: There was
some critique of the way it
was being covered by media.
This victim-blaming notion,
what did the woman do
to bring this upon herself?
"What did she wear? Why did she
put herself in that position?"
SPEAKER 10:
I wouldn't have thought twice
to go on that submarine,
because it was the job
that she was gonna do.
SPEAKER 11:
She followed the book
in every sense of the word.
SPEAKER 12:
It is the most terrifying case
I ever engaged myself in.
How on Earth did you think
you would be able
to get away with this?
SPEAKER 12: It's impossible to
imagine that something like that
could happen
to someone like her.
SPEAKER 3: They cannot identify
with this young woman who...
just wanted to do her job.